i think it was right before hentai haven
got shut down as well yeah i remember
they like messaged me
being like hey do you want to promote
like our merch line
and i'm like i'm not promoting a merch
line for a [ __ ] pirating website like
i'm sorry like
that's like if that's like if pirate bay
was like bro holy [ __ ]
we've got like these like actually yeah
no no no no no like i can say that
because they're gone but
like yeah they they fully did that and
and i i remember i missed just a few
people just being like does this
does this seem right like i don't
you're not the only person but it wasn't
hentai haven oh really it was kiss anime
really yeah yeah yeah so kiss anime were
going to open like a store
they weren't going to open a store and
they messaged me being like hey do you
want to promote our store
and i'm i was there sitting are these
guys for real
what makes you think you're going to get
away with this you know and they they
had like the ins they had the an entire
store page that they
like linked me to and they are like they
had obviously it was like
official products that were being sold
unofficially
right were they like typing to you or
writing to you in clear english or was
it broken no
it was it was actually clear clear was
it was it in russian
no it was like a proper store and
everything and i'm just like man the
these yeah that's the thing the balls on
this guys the hansa haven store as well
was like
he he had already even made like a
landing page for it and he was like this
is the lineup for the stuff and it was
like
t-shirts obviously it wasn't anything
like too like amazingly well designed
but you know it was just simple stuff
like just
the hentai haven logo on a t-shirt or
something and i'm like
uh no and then two weeks later i think
yeah i think it was maybe like
two or three weeks later they got like
you know that whole thing happened where
they got shut down right so i i wonder
if
it comes from disdain from the major
companies more so than
them because they don't actively brand
anything they don't do anything they
don't have like a
heehee funny twitter account right like
yeah like all like kiss anime never did
anything i think it's just because
it's all community dreams i think i
think a lot of the community just does
not like
the you know the big guys which you know
whatever easy to share
too yeah there they are your friend
doesn't have an account and they're new
to anime and you're trying to get to the
anime you'll link them to like a pirate
scientist and also it works on every
in every country right yeah yeah yeah
official stuff so like i i do think
there is a space for piracy i mean i
made an entire video on fan subs and how
that was like really really important
for the community and how it helped it
grow
and i will make that argument that i i
do think there is a space where
piracy does did very much play a part in
helping anime grow especially
abroad but i think it's gotten to the
point now that anime
i i don't know it's it doesn't have that
same effect anymore because anime is now
big enough where
everyone knows anime yeah yeah so i
think the
you know i think it's there's still like
a lot of countries
where that kind of need piracy to help
boost boost like anime to make this
a truly global medium but places like
the us and like the uk and you know
places where you have a lot more
accessibility and the phantom is a bit
bigger
it's like that argument doesn't hold as
much water as it did
[ __ ] 10 years ago or something like
that yeah i mean i mean 10 years ago i
mean
not even further beyond that right the
whole western community
came from piracy right because you had
to get like a bootleg like
v8 jet v why'd i say h like that
tape right you had to get a bootleg one
that was all shared around it was all
piracy but obviously like you said it's
grown out of that and i guess
some people want to hold on to that and
argue that i think that's the biggest
problem though right is that
a lot of the a lot of the discussion
that revolves especially around anime
piracy is like both sides of the
argument is
very very much like situated on both
sides of the spectrum right it's like
you either
hard agree that piracy and anime is bad
or you
hard disagree like yeah there's very
rarely any people who are kind of like
there's benefits but there's also
demerits to it because
i'm definitely someone who's in the
middle yeah i'm like yeah it's
it's hard for me to get involved in like
any discussion on twitter because
you if you say anything ever you put
they even either put you on one side or
the other yeah
you you're either like like hard into
piracy or you're like a [ __ ]
crunchyroll in funimation or book walker
yeah
right filthy books
no i work at book walkers i i know
probably shouldn't say this but i'm in
between like yeah yeah the only reason
like i'm technically in this industry or
i got interested was because
there were pirate sites right yeah i got
you into it right yeah yeah
and i got into it and i mean now there's
just so many subtitles available
yeah many platforms there's really no
excuse but you know if
you want to see something fast and in
low quality and maybe the translations
aren't because it's stuck in netflix
uh yeah one one one question one one
question i always had
about you know on the japanese side of
things is that how aware are the
japanese companies of all these pirate
sites
very aware are they very aware yeah i've
talked it feels very japanese like we
don't care i sleep oh you're pirating or
anime
i'm woke like no they care they're very
strict especially
like not talking about like websites but
for example youtube
yeah yeah we know yeah yeah fair use
fair use is another thing in japan we've
worked with
sponsors right if we want to show just a
screenshot of an anime
if if they're sponsoring it they're like
they'll bring that up they're like do
you have rights to show the screenshot
and it's
like it doesn't matter if they have a
problem like because i guess the youtube
mentality is right if it's a problem
they'll
let us know right yeah they'll take
without copywriters right whatever we'll
find it or if it's if it's really unfair
and i've just uploaded the 10 minute
family guy or 24-hour family guy stream
yeah i probably shouldn't be doing it
yeah right but most of the time it's
like if they have a problem
they can come and tell us yeah right
yeah i feel like they're very much a
risk-averse mindset where it's like just
don't ever allow that situation to
happen yeah